Neutrality it won't get you a statue
but it'll certainly happen keeping you alive
utility has consequences too
you're right I'm right well that's deeply worrying
everything that's happening
it's all connected when she's at the center of it
if war is coming there is no hiding her from it
you sure about this are you
away
from yourself
the dangers we've seen foretelling
even more menacing future
for the first time I
understand real fear thank you
we're witches is that sir
I'll never get over how cute they look
for Monsters and they're like no please
don't trust me and then wow just like a
boatload of fangs all up in your business
all I want is for us to stay together
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie Netflix
dropped a new Witcher season 3 trailer there's
a whole bunch of new footage it's actually pretty
big trailer so we'll break it all down the other
big thing is this is meant to be Henry cavill's
last season on The Witcher even though the show
is continuing so I'll explain what's going on with
that too if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos they're
breaking the season into two halves they're
doing a stranger things like they did that during
season four stranger things they'll do it during
season five as well where they release the first
five episodes then they released the last three
episodes about a month later but the big thing
during this is they're adapting Blood of Elves
which is just the next book in the story based
on what they adapted last season even though they
change a lot of things from the books just going
through the trailer of shot by shot just because
there's so much stuff in here they start at the
ruins of the sheraweed which is a big place for
the elves and he talks about neutrality neutrality
will get you nowhere but the thing is is that he's
trying to convince Ciri that neutrality is the
best way to survive because this is a reminder
of what happened to the elves about how they were
killed off on the other side of this is meant to
be Yennefer like she's so slowly kind of winning
over the team like she's slowly making amends for
what she did last season trying to kill Ciri
to get her power back I'm sure there'll be a
couple conversations about that at the beginning
of the Season sorry I tried to kill you because
one of the other big things during the trailer
like one of the big themes that you see is Ciri
learning magic from yennefer and the whole idea is
I think by the end of the season they're on their
way to aratuza so that she can learn even more
magic she's meant to be one of the most powerful
characters in The Witcher Universe just because
of her Elder blood Powers but one of the other
things in the trailer too is her showing off her
Witcher training fighting a bunch of Monsters the
whole idea is that geralt and Yennefer have
been trying to teach her to hone her skills
so that she can protect herself previously
she was kind of like a grogu character super
powerful but needed a lot of protection but just
like on the Mandalorian grogu is slowly becoming
a Mandalorian honing those skills more practical
fighting skills he's also deepening his connection
to the force becoming more powerful because
when geralt is talking about neutrality the
other big thing that's happening like you have
all these different sides that are warring with
each other you have serious father Emperor Emhyr
of nilfgaard that wants her for her power you have
the wild hunt who's coming from that other planet
that want her for her power and you also have a
bunch of elves in the trailer here that want her
for her power so everybody is trying to Vibe for
Ciri for good or for worse most of them for worse
one of the other interesting things I was really
surprised by this is when you see them fighting
the elves in the ruins here Robbie Amell of all
people who most of you probably remember from
the arrowverse or from some other recent movie
he's been in a bunch of stuff recently is going
to be part of these elves but he's not featured
anywhere in the trailer I think he's supposed to
have a big scar on his face during the fight here
it looks like Yennefer's trying to open that
big portal then pretty much anytime you see
anything in the trailer being set on fire or fire
being shot at people it's probably Rience who's
working for vilgaforce who's working for Emperor
Emhyr so this is nilfgaard basically coming for
Ciri. Rience's is meant to be a proxy for a lot
of that story that's this is the way it plays
out in the books too you see him fighting both
Yennefer and both geralt in a bunch of different
scenes and setting a lot of their houses on fire
across the way because one of the other big Clips
during this you actually see them living life as a
family it's meant to be this picture of what their
life could be like so you meant to look at it from
both geralt and serious perspective like there's
a voiceover from Syria in the trailer where she
says I want to keep us together like she wants to
be a family with them because they're kind of like
her adoptive parents and geralt is also starting
to grow to enjoy this he starts to think of Ciri
as a daughter a lot like the Mandalorian there's
a lot of comparisons with the Mandalorian because
the way he's trying to protect Ciri and teach her
to protect herself is the same way the Mando is
doing with grogu one of the big things about The
Witcher is the monsters themselves and they do try
to feature a couple big monster fights the fight
in the Maze is just meant to show up the things
that Ciri learned from all of her fight training
during season two like oh see she could actually
protect herself a little bit like she avoids the
monster the wild Hunt aren't specifically monsters
themselves like that's just armor they just use
magic to modulate their voices during my previous
videos like my last trailer video I talked about
the White Frost film because that's like the
main big bad of all the Witcher swords like all
the books everything even the games the way they
portrayed that in the video games is more of a
force of nature that Ciri has to fight but the way
that the TV show portrayed it is that it's more
of a person behind that it seemed like ultimately
the white Frost was trying to manipulate everyone
including the wild Hunt themselves so we'll see
how they developed that during season three like
they plan on going Five Seasons we'll see how long
it winds up going with Liam Hemsworth because they
did say that they plan on going through season
five in their shooting season 4 and season five
back to back so even if people have a problem
once Liam Hemsworth takes over during season
four they'll have already filmed season five so
like it'll already be in the can so I'm assuming
if they reveal what's really going on with the
white frost on the TV show version The Witcher it
won't be until like season five and we might get
some Clues this season it seems like mostly during
season three it's more about revealing what the
Wild Hunt wants with Ciri and them learning about
that because geralt hasn't completely figured
that out yet even though if you've read the books
or you played the games you know what's going on
with the wild Hunt in Eredin the other interesting
thing too is it seems like their boat fight
against this monster while they're on their way
to aratuza is against a monster that was supposed
to be during season 2 because it's featured on
this season 2 poster that they revealed maybe they
just cut it for time or something or decided to
move it to season three this shot of Ciri is at
a festival they're looking at a caged monster and
I believe it's meant to be a wyvern they have a
couple scenes of geralt and Yennefer at a festival
like it's real quick blink and you'll miss it but
it's them sort of rekindling their love for each
other because remember Geralt wasn't a big fan of
yennefer during season two because she was trying
to kill Ciri this is meant to be a shot of sintra
this is meant to be a shot of her father Emperor
Emhyr looking at her picture when she was younger
K here is another big villain during the season
but he's not featured a lot during the trailer
like he's still a big thing during this season
I think they're slowly transitioning to the idea
that Phil gaforts is behind this too working with
Emperor Emhyr so they want to slowly move on to
like the next level of big bads and they just
introduced Emperor Emhyr in a big way during last
season they had that funny scene in the woods with
geralt and jaskir where geralt agrees that he has
the right idea and that worries him just because
he's supposed to be a fool wait a minute you agree
with me this is deeply worrying something very bad
must be coming in fact just based on the trailer
several bad things are coming from all different
factions these scenes of geralt and Yennefer at
the ball might be from the thaenedd ball from time
of contempt which might happen somewhere around
the middle of the Season it does seem like they're
going to spill into the next part of the story too
like not just Blood of Elves they've already been
big balls that are atuza in previous Seasons this
one is meant to be even bigger and even though
I just mentioned what's happening with vilgafore
it's working with Emperor Emhyr the Nilfguardians
the whole idea is that the Council of sorcerers
also wants Ciri for her power too so they get
another faction they also teased djkstra here
played by Graham McTavish becoming a bigger threat
during the next season too and if it wasn't clear
last season the owl that he kept talking to was
philippa's character this person here the whole
idea is that even though there's this big conflict
and everybody is coming for Ciri to take her for
her power there's also Emperor Emhyr who's trying
to conquer and unite the entire continent so you
have this big Supernatural battle going on around
Ciri but also this very practical regular type
of battle fighting for Supremacy in the continent
probably one of the other biggest changes from
previous seasons is that you see the entire family
so to speak like make all the Vin Diesel memes
that you want family fighting together because
now Ciri does have at least a little bit of skill
so she's getting better she's not that great a
fighter but she's getting better like I said
though this will be Henry cavill's final season
of The Witcher like he's basically just moving on
to his own projects like I released that Warhammer
trailer video that he posted he's going to be
working on a Warhammer Series in Warhammer movies
at Amazon part of the idea too is I think that he
wanted more creative control and he just didn't
have that on The Witcher like he didn't agree with
what they were doing changing some of the story he
wanted to do some other things with the character
and they had other ideas so even though it sucks
that he is leaving The Witcher he is moving on
to a big Warhammer series it should be really
exciting to see what he does with that the other
really big thing that's happening is that Marvel's
secret Invasion episodes are starting in the next
couple of weeks I'll be doing episode videos for
that click here to watch the first five minutes
of secret Invasion episode one it's the entire
opening scene and click here for my Henry Cavill
Warhammer trailer video to learn about that series
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!